carbon is a fantastically important
element there probably far more
molecules that contain carbon than any
other element the reason why you can get
so many carbon compounds is that carbon
atoms form chains very very easily
sometimes millions of atoms long if you
just have atoms that will form one or
two bonds then you can't build up huge
numbers of molecules but if there's no
limit to the number of bonds you can
make you can make things that are really
long it's like the difference between
the lorry the truck which can pull if
you're lucky one trailer or perhaps two
and the train where you can put as many
wagons or carriages as you want
so you can get really long train so it's
just the same with carbon
so carbon it's around us everywhere
we're all carbon there's lots of carbon
in us in all the hydrocarbons within our
body lots of those are the structures
inside us and many many of the materials
that we use every day in fact a majority
of us used carbon in the form of fuels
everyday to get to work or to go home
without carbon we couldn't exist your
carbon i'm carbon we have bones made out
of calcium but the important parts our
brains contain largely carbon they
contain nitrogen and oxygen and hydrogen
as well but carbons the key carbon is
one of the very few elements that has
given rise to a whole area of chemistry
organic chemistry the chemistry of
carbon compounds is almost a separate
discipline from some other areas of
chemistry and most of the molecules that
we use for plastics for pharmaceutical
products for our food are all carbon
compounds carbon is an extremely common
element but if it comes in a number of
different allotropes so different forms
and this one here this is actually some
charcoal which is just simple carbons
very very similar in very very in
fashion to graphite you can find lumps
of carbon lying around this is a piece
here that I found on the beach on the
northeast of England it's a piece of
coal it's not absolutely pure carbon but
it is a very high proportion of carbon
and compared to other stones of this
sort of size it's really quite light
more recently people have discovered
diamonds and of course graphite which is
the black material that you get in
pencils people call them LED pencils but
they actually contain the form of carbon
called graphite so carbon comes as
graphite as diamond and also as
buckyballs or fullerenes so the carbon
here which is a bit like the graphite is
very amorphous and it's very very
free-flowing so we're going to pour a
little bit of the car
onto the paper so that you can see so
you can see it's a very light powder and
you can see that it's a very very nice
easily maneuverable easily workable
material the thing that's really
exciting is that in the last 20 years
people have discovered new forms of
carbon now this is extraordinary people
have known of carbon for thousands of
years even longer and suddenly in the
last 20 years the number of different
types of carbon has grown enormously I
have a colleague who's a specialist in
these new forms of carbon and I went and
asked him for a model and he gave me a
whole suitcase of models let me show you
so what do we got first of all this is a
model of graphite the materials that's
in the middle of pencils and it consists
of layers of rings of hexagonal rings of
carbon atoms that six carbon atoms and
they're joined together in layers can
you see here there these purple bonds in
between them you can see they're not
very strong ones even broken here very
recently in the last 10 years it's been
discovered that using a piece of
sellotape you can pull off these layers
and make single sheets of these carbon
atoms
it's called graphene the 2010 Nobel
Prize for Physics was given to two
scientists for discovering graphene
there's this structure here where each
carbon atom is joined to four others in
this sort of tetrahedral pattern
tetrahedron is this group one in the
middle with four rounded and this is
Dimond it's really very strong whichever
way you squash it it's strong you can't
peel off layers of diamonds
with a piece of cellular tape damn it's
a colorless and to understand why you
have to understand what gives rise to
color and the color of anything might
tie anything are caused by electrons in
the molecules or material and they
absorb energy and go from one level to
another in diamond there are bonds
between all the carbon atoms that use
all the electrons the electrons are very
tightly bound and none of them can
change their energy state so you get no
absorption at least in the visible
region of the spectrum on the other hand
with graphite the electrons are less
strongly bound in fact it conducts
electricity and it's black because the
electrons will absorb all wavelengths of
visible light right from the blue to the
red so that it looks black because none
of the light is reflected from it inside
here we have the famous molecule C 60
like a football 60 carbon atoms and the
Ray has put a little one inside here but
forget that for a moment so you can have
this molecule C 60 first discovered in
the late 1980s and only isolated in the
early 1990s and there is a very similar
molecule which looks a bit more squashed
which is C's 70 now these are also
colored but their color is rather
different have a look here I've got two
samples one of C 60 and one of C 70 both
of them dissolved up in the solvent
toluene so if you look here C 70 is a
reddish brown color and C 60 in the
solvent has a beautiful color I call it
purple other people call it magenta back
to the box and in here we have the final
form of carbon which are called
nanotubes these are whole tubes made up
of hex
guns you have two sorts one which is
closed at the end and this one here
which is open rather like a basket you
can put things inside it the final model
is graphene this material that you can
peel off graphite with cellotape sticky
tape and the reason that people get so
excited is first of all this is a very
thin material it's only one atom thick
and you can react the carbon atoms on
here with all sorts of different
molecules you can make very strong
materials you can start making
electronics Carbon computers things like
that and many people believe that
graphene is one of the materials of the
future this is one of andrae's exhibits
he uses it in exhibitions to measure
electrical conductivity you see if you
take a piece of metal like this coin and
you put the two electrodes on there you
can see it conducts electricity all the
lights light up and the needle goes
across so he's got different samples
this one here is CO and this is graphite
so there's a track of this is a photo
and this is a track of Co between two
metal electrodes and you can see if we
put the electrodes on here the co
doesn't conduct electricity at all
however if we take the graphite and do
the same it conducts electricity not
very well but you can see you do get
some electricity going through on his
other sheet he's got a sample of c60 and
here of the carbon nanotubes and you can
see the c60 doesn't conduct electricity
either the electrons can't jump between
one molecule in the other but when you
come to the carbon nanotubes which are
long long molecules they conduct
electricity really well
not quite as well as a metal but pretty
close